- I was a hometown kid.
I was a Player of the Year candidate.
- [Announcer]: Here comes the All-America!
- The nation's leading scorer at nearly 29 points per game.
- [Mark Few]: The bigger the moment, you know, the better he was.
- [Announcer]: Kid has been compared to Larry Bird.
- I think I had five 40-point games that season. I was really rolling offensively.
My expectation was Final Four, to be honest.
- [Announcer]: Now, let's head courtside along with
former Gonzaga standout Adam Morrison.
- Nobody prepares you for fame.
I get remembered for showing emotion.
But during that season,
I felt that I was one of the better players in college basketball,
and I think I proved that.
- [Announcer]: Here's Morrison. Book it.
- There he is again!
He's got 34.
- I was a big Larry Bird fan
and I wanted to be like him in every aspect.
So it kinda came and stuck.
- [Announcer]: He told me that he studies Larry Bird.
- He obviously loved Larry Bird
and looked up to Larry Bird.
I mean, and, you know,
the elbow—pocket was way up high.
- The mustache,
everybody remembers his.
So that was part of it,
and then the media took ahold of it,
and it kinda just took a life upon itself.
Looking back on it now,
there's times where I'm like—
But also it created a brand for myself.
- Once you watch him for a while,
you realize it's different,
and it's—and it's unorthodox
but it's incredibly effective.
I mean, the way he can really,
really, really score the ball.
- [Announcer]: Morrison falling away from the corner!
- It was fun because I had the ultimate green light.
I could shoot whenever I wanted.
- [Announcer]: Morrison tries one from about
30 feet away!
- Well, I was obviously a very emotional player.
It created an image
and so much media attention as well.
- He had a tendency to talk,
and that kinda got him going.
And that was just Adam
That year with Adam,
it was amazing.
Not only were we highly ranked,
but he was such an entity that everybody wanted to see.
I mean,
he had to check in under aliases,
you know, in hotels.
- Dirk Diggler.
I know I used Dirk Diggler for a while
which, um, hopefully my kids don't watch this.
- And then we’d walk into these arenas
and they were raring to go hours before tip.
And he would just thrive in that environment.
- [Announcer]: He's like the fifth Beatle with the paparazzi following him.
- [Crowd chanting]: One more year! One more year!
- It was such a whirlwind around me.
You know, I look at a double-edged sword.
It was great, but also there was times where I was like,
“Can I just disappear and just be a normal college kid?”
I felt a little bit bad
that it took away from kind of my other teammates’ success
but also it helped elevate the program and
gave us an opportunity to take a step from, you know,
mid-major and now to a true powerhouse.
There was so much pressure
because of who I was and how the season progressed.
We thought we were a Final Four team.
- [Announcer]: Adam Morrison, National Player of the Year candidate,
trying to put Gonzaga on his back on a tournament run.
- We were a three seed that year,
but we liked our draw.
- [Announcer]: Morrison for the lead.
Got it!
- I hit a three late in that game down the stretch
to really extend ourselves.
We had a tough game against Indiana
and squeaked by in the second round.
And then everybody knows the UCLA game.
- [Announcer]: UCLA and Gonzaga
for a trip to the final eight.
- Here comes the All-America.
- We hadn’t been in the Sweet 16 in my two years before that.
We lost in the second round.
So there was a lot of pressure on us, for sure.
- [Announcer]: Gonzaga by 17.
Morrison, quick-release three.
Pure, and the foul!
- We weren’t looking ahead, but when you're up 17
at one point,
it’s hard not to a little bit.
- [Announcer]: Afflalo, block.
Gets his own rebound.
And-1!
Now we've got a ballgame.
- This one's not over.
- Here come the Bruins!
- Literally everything that had to go right for them down the stretch did.
Some guys hit some pretty amazing shots for them.
You know, it was just, just one of those games.
- [Announcer]: Farmar, runner,
got it!
- It just kinda happened in a fog.
- [Announcer]: Morrison, step-back jumper, deep,
off the heel.
Loose ball...
and a foul!
It will go against Batista.
- That's one of my biggest regrets.
I should have bounced him down and probably
got closer and tried to get fouled.
And once I missed that, everything kinda—domino effect,
and then got a little bit crazy.
- [Announcer]: 71-70.
They throw it to Morrison.
He holds on.
- You don’t wanna foul Morrison.
You make him get it over half court.
You know you got a foul.
- And a steal!
Farmar,
inside
the freshman up...
ohhh, and they go in front!
Raivio,
last chance today—
oh, Mbah a Moute!
- Unbelievable!
- Oh, what a game!
- What a game!
- Unbelievable!
- UCLA! Unbelievable!
- Are you kidding me?!
- Adam Morrison,
is this it for him?
After leading the entire ballgame.
- Look up and we’re down.
It was tough.
It was tough to handle, to be honest.
I'm sure there's time
when he probably still thinks about it
to this day.
- [Announcer]: The frontcourt,
Batista with the catch…
And that’s it!
What a comeback!
U-C-L-A
defeats Gonzaga,
73-71,
after being down by 17!
- I was gonna go to the NBA.
I knew it was my last game.
Local kid
and a Gonzaga kid for my whole life.
It was very emotional to,
to lose that way.
It wasn't like we, you know,
just got our butts kicked and
then I just showed emotion like that.
We were ahead 17.
- It's kinda how he's wired,
which is, which is what you respect.
- If that happened now
it’d be poignant and,
“Look at this
man showing emotion.
How great is this?”
and all that stuff.
So,
you know, it's funny how culture changes
and everything shifts,
but I was the first guy to do it, and so I got hammered for it,
which is OK.
It happens.
But if we win that game,
I'm never remembered for that.
The previous guy who did the color
took another job in town,
and so they just called me one day
and said, “Do you wanna give it a shot?”
I've never had any experience.
There's times when I wish I was wearing a uniform again
because it’d be fun to play in this offense.
It helps me stay around the game and
watch basketball for a living.
It's good, good life.
I've had really good life experiences because of basketball,
and especially that season.
People have asked me,
“Whenever you hear UCLA,
does it freak you out?”
I was like, “No,
it's all right.
It's one loss.”
It happens and
I'm not,
I'm not ashamed of showing emotion
to be honest.